hey
guys
this morning on the dish it was quite a
summer for Portland Oregon Chef Gregory
gourde just last month he opened his
groundbreaking restaurant Khan featuring
delectable dishes from his Caribbean
Heritage and in June his first cookbook
everyone's table won a prestigious James
Beard book award but along with his own
success he's also trying to make a
difference in his adopted City still
suffering from the lingering effects of
the pandemic social unrest and
homelessness we talked about it all on a
recent visit
oh wow Bridge City there's one there's
like Seven Bridges right there wow from
high above the city he loves Chef
Gregory gourde sees Portland's promise
and his part in it I hope that everyone
on my team and I and everything that
we're trying to do at Khan can help
rebuild the city help push money back
into the economy create jobs and get
people back to our state to see just how
unique and interesting a place like
Portland Oregon is should we go in yes
let's do it all right all right gordae
invited us in to Khan's brand new
kitchen
where he fused is local Bounty
with his Haitian culture this whole
salad is a combination of fresh bright
with Savory soulfuls this is going to
give it some depth and then we just go
nuts with the berries then we're going
to add some crispy plantain chips just
add a little texture I don't see how all
of these things all right together okay
are gonna I can't wait to show you I'm
not the chef and show me there you go
he did
I'm still tasting okay okay they unfold
there's a lot going on it's really
delightful after taking a Hiatus from
running departure at the Nines Hotel in
Portland gourde competed on two seasons
of Top Chef where he made it to both
finals you know the truth is a lot of
people have watched Top Chef and they
saw me create this Haitian concept that
really was a pit of a moment in just
seeing the global Haitian Community just
like freak out and all these iconic
Asian dishes on National Television
something you don't see that often most
recently I was able to cook for Oprah so
is your restaurant gonna be Haitian yes
my restaurant is a Wood-Fired Haitian
Concept in Oregon in Oregon
but for her to post about that meal and
to be eating soup which is another
really important Haitian dish it's our
freedom soup
[Music]
the Haitian Community lit up you know
from Haiti to Canada and all over the
world as someone who understands that I
have a platform I want to use my
platform to do as much good as possible
so it just became crystal clear that my
restaurant had to be Haitian but early
on gourde's career path wasn't clear a
pre-med major at NYU he transferred to
the University of Montana to study
wildlife biology before graduating with
a degree in French that's when and where
he discovered his passion for cooking he
then enrolled into The Culinary
Institute of America where he earned an
internship with Chef John George Who
mentored him for almost seven years at
the same time he struggled with
addiction I was irresponsible really let
down a lot of people that were important
to me in my life it's what brought him
from New York to the Northwest I met
some chefs who were in Alcoholics
Anonymous and saw what they had they
seemed happy they were working and one
day I just realized I needed some help
had some friends in a and accidentally
take me to my first meeting and I've
been able to you know stay sober and
it's been the best 13 years of my life
it's why his bar menu is stacked with
zero proof options this is a soursop
drink lemon juice coconut water coconut
milk and then soursop it's sweet with a
little bit of maple syrup so what is
sour sauce soursop is a tropical fruit
it's kind of like pineapple and lychee
mixed together but once you taste it to
me all it tastes like is a Tropics
but we got a little ahead of our tasting
so what we do here is a combination of
traditionally inspired Haitian dishes
Chef gourde began with a sampling of his
Haitian appetizer today we have don't
mind my fingers today we have a salt Cod
filling okay a flicky cod fish Patty
made with plant-based butter I went off
about 13 years ago gluten and dairy and
I discovered that my body feels much
better off it a lot of the patient
Cuisine is actually already gluten free
and dairy free his Savory stew made of
eggplant carrots squash and onions it's
so pretty with all the fresh yes yes
flowers but if you love it so much how
come you aren't born
I'm just excited to tell you about it
everything his Mulan grilled cornmeal
porridge cooked with pepper and chilies
barbecue originated in Haiti and that
when Christopher Columbus first came to
Hispaniola as he called it he saw the
indigenous folks grilling over charcoal
and wood for the first time and so we
have a big beautiful Hearth here and we
grill a lot of things that we do and his
kidney beans and collard greens finished
off with boiled peanuts and Ode to
Haiti's West African Roots so we have
collard greens that are cooked down with
tons of onions and garlic until they're
really tender and then finished with
peanut butter that we make coconut milk
and some spiced tomatoes and then it's
garnished with boiled pickled peanuts
this is a very popular addition on our
menu but beyond the food there's been an
education
we spent a lot of time working with
Educators just so the staff here is
armed with knowledge as possible about
the history of Haiti knowledge of the
indigenous populations their genocide
both Spanish and French colonial rule
and their import of enslaved Africans
and the pride of Haiti's revolutionary
Independence we were the first black
nation first black Republic of the first
black book to free ourselves from
slavery it all comes together here at
Khan the history and the hope for a
better tomorrow you know I think
Portland is definitely a global dying
destination and it's important that we
stay on the map and I think us doing
this will really help get diners back to
our city from all over the world
so important to get Portland back on his
feet he really believes Khan and some of
his Partners can make that happen but I
brought you guys some coconut lemonade
it's something he developed Chef gordae
developed on the line it's made with
coconut water lemon juice coconut milk
and maple syrup it is so delightful that
food looks so good this looks good
Michelle but man I wish we had the food
wow it's like layer upon layer upon
layer upon layer oh well this is this is
the topics it is this has that whatever
that was that he said is the tropics
yeah sour sauce oh that's good it is
good very nice